c'est l'un des grands changements de ce
début d'année 2024 pa emploi devient
France travail depuis le 1er janvier
après l'adoption de la loi pour le plein
emploi le 18 décembre dernier le
gouvernement souhaite renforcer le suivi
des personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi mais pas que la deuxième des
choses c'est d'accompagner toutes les
entreprises parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'on offre des
services pour accompagner les
entreprises à plus recruter à mieux
recruter ça fonctionne bien 86 % d'entre
elles sont satisfaite sauf qu'on a
encore 70 % des entreprises qui
n'utilisent pas France travail mais
France travail ne va pas seulement Chang
de nom l'organisme se réorganise pour
mieux coordonner l'accueil l'orientation
l'insertion ou encore la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi il sera notamment
intégré à un réseau pour l'emploi un
réseau qui se constitue en quatre
[Musique]
entités autre changement une inscription
automatisée à France travail est prévue
pour les personnes sans emploi au plus
tard en 2025 cette mesure concerne les
demandeurs d'emploi déjà inscrits à
pleemploi les les jeunes et les
personnes handicapées accompagnées par
des missions locales ou Cap emploi mais
aussi les bénéficiaires du revenu de
solidarité active et leur conjoint si
nécessaire après cette inscription un
diagnostic approfondi est ensuite
réalisé auprès des demandeurs d'emploi
pour définir un contrat d'engagement son
but délimiter un plan d'action pour
atteindre des objectifs d'insertion
sociale et professionnelle cette loi
fixe aussi une obligation d'activité
d'au moins 15 heures par semaine des
nouveautés en cours d'application pour
l'occasion la nouvelle ministre du
Travail Catherine train s'est déplacé à
l'agence de Guill encours elle a échangé
avec conseillers et entreprises autour
de deux thématiques l'accompagnement des
entreprises pour favoriser le retour à
l'emploi et le renforcement de ces aides
auprès des publics l'émancipation de nos
concitoyens se fait par le travail
l'idée c'est de les aider à retrouver un
emploi et ici dans ce département on a
AG Guill encour une commune qui dispose
d'un nombre d'entreprises extrêmement
important nous avons échangé avec
plusieurs d'entre elles qui ont montré
combien depuis 6 mois elles avaient
elles avaient eu des réponses l'Agence
France travail de guyancour expérimente
depuis quelques mois avec 17 autres
sites en France une démarche pour
faciliter le retour ou l'accès à
l'emploi des allocataires de RSA